I think the biggest competitive advantage that young people have when starting an organization...
...is that a lot of the way things are right now is taken for granted,...
...in the sense that if you start a company now in technology,...
...you take for granted that we have persistent Wi-Fi connections and that everyone is online.
And you take for granted as well the values of your generation.
I think sometimes your competitors will be much larger, older organizations...
...and now have a mindset that it's about the old way.
So as a media company, a lot of our competitors were in the newspaper business or the magazine industry.
They have a lot of legacy stuff that not only holds them back in terms of them being able to move as fast as we are,...
...but in terms of their thinking and understanding that the world is completely different now.
...that being online makes for a completely different media experience.
And you know, for me and for us as an organization,...
...we didn't have the legacy understanding of, "Hey, we're a magazine."
We had the understanding of, "Hey, we're a blog," as we started out.
And that we just took everything that was already part of our generation as a norm.
And actually it wasn't the norm, it was a very new thing.
And we were building a very, very new company that was completely different from the ones that have been before.